et bien ce déplacement il est hautement
symbolique 1 il le doit marquer l'appui
de l'union européenne à l'ukraine et
c'est vraiment en droite ligne avec ce
que dit la présidente de la commission
européenne depuis le début de la guerre
les ukrainiens ont vocation à faire
partie de la famille européenne
d'ailleurs la présidente de la
commission ne sera pas seul vous l'avez
dit elle sera accompagné dans ce voyage
par le chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell ça aussi c'est très
important d'un point de vue diplomatique
alors on en sait très peu en fait sur
l'organisation de ce déplacement la
seule certitude c'est qu'une rencontre
est prévue avec le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky pour le reste
l'organisation reste extrêmement
discrète après cette visite a aussi
l'avant-dernier yen se rendra en pologne
elle sera à varsovie demain pour un
événement qui s'appelle stander pour you
quan c'est une conférence mondiale des
donateurs organisée par l'union
européenne et par le canada pour réunir
un maximum de dons en faveur des
ukrainiens déplacer ou ayant dû fuir
leur pays il y a quelques jours c'était
la présidente du parlement européen
robert terme est de ceux là qui
s'étaient rendues elles aussi à kiev
bref l'union européenne veut donc des
symboles forts après la révélation des
massacres de boudhha est dans une
période où les réponses d'occidental à
la russie sont marquées par un
durcissement le cinquième train de
sanctions de l'union européenne contre
la russie adopté hier soir par les 27
états membres en est un bon exemple
et justement ce cinquième train de
sanctions qu'elles en sont les détails
jean-jacques
il aura donc un embargo sur l'énergie
russe mais uniquement sur le charbon
russe pas sur le pétrole ni sur le gaz
malgré les demandes répétées de kiev le
charbon représente 45 % des importations
d'union c'est une rentrée d'argent de 4
milliards d'euros par an qui disparaît
pour l'état russe
la mesure entrera en vigueur au début du
mois d'août le temps de rompre
légalement les contrats en cours les
transports sont aussi visés les navires
us ne peuvent plus pénétrer dans les
ports de l'union même interdiction pour
les transporteurs routiers russes et
biélorusses leurs camions seront bloqués
aux frontières par ailleurs il sera
maintenant possible d'exporter vers la
russie et bien d'autres technologies des
semi conducteurs par exemple l'idée
c'est de saper au maximum l'industrie
russe en parallèle de nouvelles banques
vont avoir leur voir je les ai enfin la
liste noire de personnalités russes de
l'union s'allonge s'allonge pardon de
plus de 200 noms viennent notamment s'y
ajouter ceux de nouveaux oligarques et
des deux filles de vladimir poutine et
on parlait tout à l'heure de
durcissement occidental et bien cela se
voit aussi sur le plan militaire hier au
siège de l'otan où se réunissaient les
ministres des affaires étrangères les
alliés ont assuré qu'ils allaient
accélérer les livraisons d'armes aux
ukrainiens et ce au moment où les forces
russes sont en train de lancer une
grande offensive sur l'est de l'ukraine
et sur le dombass en parallèle le chef
de la diplomatie européenne josette
borel a proposé d'augmenter de 500
millions d'euros le financement pour la
fourniture d'armes à l'ukraine ce qui
pourrait porter rapidement l'ensemble
des aides européennes pour la fourniture
d'armement à l'ukraine à 1,5 milliard
d'euros depuis le début de la guerre